getting the new set of well uh certain
significant moment in history in actual
Factor because we've heard and you can
see at the bottom of your screen there
now that Lord David Trimble the former
first minister of Northern Ireland has
passed away and uh there he is he became
uh best known I suppose internationally
for of course he won the Nobel Peace
Prize for that for um negotiating uh the
Good Friday agreement uh alongside that
man not the one in the middle uh it's uh
Bono from U2 but uh John Hume from the
sdlp uh they both won the Nobel Peace
Prize for that historic agreement in
1988 which set up that power sharing
executive of which he became the first
Minister uh former leader of the Ulster
unionist party as David Trimble as well
and as you can see there the family have
just released a short statement that he
passed away peacefully earlier today
following a short illness so we'll be
talking to to our Island correspondent
David Blevins in a little bit to assess
the life and times and this huge
significance and influence of Lord
Trimble upon the the history of Ireland
and indeed these islands so let's I
think I am joined at this very moment
bye David Blevins if somebody could
confirm that to me that is confirmed
David
um this is as I say a a huge moment in
the in the history of of these islands
and Beyond
it is indeed David Trimble was the
co-architect of the Good Friday
agreement he was the unionist leader who
showed enormous courage in signing up to
the deal that had been brokered by
Senator George Mitchell back in 1998
many people will remember that the
Democratic unionist party leader the
Reverend Ian Paisley rejected the Deal
completely at that stage so it was an
enormous risk for David Trimble as
leader of the Ulster unionist party to
say yes to the deal but he was convinced
Friday agreement would secure Northern
Ireland's future as part of the United
Kingdom and so he took that
his own party and I think it was it is
only really with history that we are
able to recognize how courageous a
decision that was he served as the
Member of Parliament for upper van for a
number of years but was eventually
ousted by the dup elevated to the Lords
he served as a member of the upper house
for a number of years but the Lord
Trimble had been ill in recent weeks he
appeared recently at the unveiling of a
portrait at Queen's University and it
was quite apparent that he was
struggling with his health but I
but a contribution he made to the search
for Peace On This Island having gone
from a very hard-line position many
people will remember him
protesting over the uh prohibition the
prohibition of the drum creeper raid
back in the 1990s to a position where he
became more compromising and ultimately
as a result of that Northern Ireland was
able to see the brokering of that
historic agreement in 1998.
and what was his view David in the last
few years on The Rao about the Northern
Ireland protocol he had a little bit of
a warning for unionist India about the
approach to take yes David trim Mel was
always very empty the EU and even though
the Ulster unionist party of today tends
to take a slightly more moderate view on
it he did Welcome the Medicine of the UK
to leave the European Union but he was
very very deeply concerned about the
Northern Ireland protocol and that
despite what had been achieved through
the Good Friday agreement which of
course is underpinned by what's
described as the principle of consent
that there will never be any change to
the Constitutional position of Northern
Ireland as part of the United Kingdom on
less and until the majority of people in
Northern Ireland vote for that kind of
change he was concerned that the
protocol which of course the way they
avoided a hard border on this island by
establishing a trade Border in the rhc
had raised the quest question of
Northern Ireland's constitutional
position as part of the United Kingdom
and with adamant that the protocol
needed to be
still about that than any other issue in
in recent years
and just David you touched on it just
the the extent of the gamble he took in
and especially for the party he led the
Ulster unionist party which of course
had been dominant in Northern Ireland
since its foundation and as you say now
eclipsed by the Democratic unionist
Party
difficult probably for people today
to really fully understand the extent of
the decision that he took bearing in
mind that in 1998 we were only four
years after the IRA ceasefire and
because of the courageous decision of
the Nationalist leader John Hume the
other co-architect of the Good Friday
agreement in effect
bringing Shin fee in from the cold
bringing Shin faint to the negotiating
table and you will remember the enormous
decision it was for Jerry Adams and
Martin McGinnis to be in common involved
in the political process and the IRA to
leave behind what it described as the
armed struggle that was
that was always going to face quite a
challenge in persuading them that a deal
could be done that would secure Northern
Ireland's place in the United Kingdom
until the majority of people here voted
otherwise but he did manage to persuade
enough unionists to come with them on
that journey and despite as I say
opposition from without his party and
from within party he stayed the course
really until eventually I think because
of delays over the decommissioning of
Ira weapons the dup were mounted did
manage to eclipse the Ulster unionist
party but I think all through German it
is worth reflecting tonight on the fact
that in the course of the last five
years we've now lost Martin McGinnis
we've lost uh John Hume we've lost David
Trimble on a very short time before that
we lost the Reverend Ian Paisley so we
really are witnessing at the end of an
era in Northern Ireland politics
in a year when we've had an election
that saw Shin fee and become the largest
party at Stormwind a nationalist first
Minister elect for the very first time